and the damage you see there in
charlie's report the attacks on
residential neighborhoods on civilians
is why so many people are now refugees
heading for the borders here in poland
officials say around a million ukrainian
refugees have already arrived in this
country that has since russia invaded
back on february 24th that is more
arrivals than any of ukraine's neighbors
and we are looking at a wave of refugees
larger and quicker building than at any
time since world war ii
hundreds of thousands more are expected
to arrive soon are arriving in fact
right now after making their way out of
cities and the war zone many of them
will cross the border again here in
medica you're looking at pictures from
yesterday we met dozens of families some
so overcome when we asked them what they
had seen what they were fleeing they
couldn't talk about it but some would
and this is their story
we had heard about a new exodus arriving
from ukraine
but nothing prepared us for the sight of
so many people walking out of their
homeland
the mothers and grandmothers the
children so many in their mother's arms
in strollers holding hands some no
taller than their family's luggage and
then there were those we saw waiting for
their families to arrive like this woman
in red we saw standing alone desperate
for an end to the violence i love
russian people
i love american people
further up the path a little boy in a
dinosaur hat nuzzled into his mother's
neck exhausted after rushing overnight
by bus to the border
the day before his mother said three of
her friends were shot in the fighting
and that's not all
hangings rape
killings yes another friend was hung she
claims by the russians another she told
us was raped
she traveled with almost nothing but in
a box of donations nearby she found her
son a new toy a little yellow school bus
and it made us wonder what does a kid
bring on a trip like this one barbie
dolls turn out to be one answer maybe a
bag of stuffed animals or just a single
favorite like era the penguin hi i'm
tony who we met riding high on her
father's shoulders welcome to poland era
of the penguin what about those fathers
and sons and brothers they can't go any
further all the men aged 18 to 60 in
ukraine are required to stay and fight
those allowed to leave are left worrying
about those who can't or in some cases
won't
we found katya and her children in a
quiet area warming themselves by a fire
she's worried about her brother who was
fighting and her parents who were older
and insisted on staying
but amid the fear and exhaustion we also
found signs of kindness volunteers with
warm food and drinks
boxes and boxes of supplies
but after walking for days and for miles
what people really want
is just a place to sit down and get warm
when refugees are ready to move on
there's a bus to a more permanent relief
center a former high-end shopping mall
converted into a shelter now housing
hundreds here they can finally charge
their phones and wait for the call that
everyone is waiting for
the call that the war is over that they
can go home
before home
is gone forever
and that shelter there not far from
where we're standing is also a decision
point as those refugees who've made it
across the border have a chance to
decide where they will go in europe